y una gira internacional no exenta de
polémicas a pocas semanas de salir de su
cargo mike pompeo se convierte en el
primer secretario de estado de eeuu que
visita los altos del golán una zona
fronteriza que israel le arrebató a
siria en 1967 y que hoy sigue en disputa
puedes quedarte mirando fijamente lo que
está al otro lado de la frontera y negar
el punto central que el presidente trump
reconoció lo que los presidentes
anteriores se han negado a hacer esto es
una parte de israel y una parte central
de israel sandro poder verlo en 2019 el
presidente de donald trump declaró la
soberanía israelí sobre los altos del
golán además de visitar la zona el
secretario de estado también viajó a
unos asentamientos israelíes en
cisjordania considerados por el derecho
internacional como ilegales desde allí
prometió nuevas pautas para que los
productos fabricados en las ocupaciones
tengan el sello de hecho en israel en
vez de portar la marca especial que
tienen actualmente siria rechazó la
visita de pompeo y la consideró una
provocación y los palestinos también
criticaron a pompei
cuando pompeo habla de legalizar los
productos de los asentamientos israelíes
eso va en contra del consejo de derechos
humanos que enfatizó que los productos
de estos asentamientos deberían ser
etiquetados y dados en día
voy a tratar con las empresas de los
asentamientos ilegales sino ponerlas en
la lista negra eso va en contra de todas
las decisiones internacionales y del
derecho internacional es alejar el
círculo para child herido juan durán y
pompeo seguirá su gira internacional en
emiratos árabes unidos qatar y arabia
saudita